get your top five takeaways rod the
patriots they just keep on winning
football games what's the biggest reason
when you look at this team coming
together what is it that's catching your
eye
i'm trusting the coach bill belichick is
one of those guys he focuses on when he
talks about doing your job it's about
doing the fundamentals of your job and
doing your job right all the time so now
that your teammate can trust you and
that's what i see what's happening when
he's talking to them as far as
fundamental football setting the edge
they're doing a great job of setting the
edge when they double team a guy they do
a great job of taking them away earlier
in the season they didn't do that they
had fumbles they uh penalties turnovers
all these different things and they
weren't doing their jobs they weren't
doing the fundamentals of of football
and they weren't having success now you
see those guys are starting to trust
coach belichick a lot more they're
starting to do the little things that it
takes and now they're just out there
playing and having fun playing football
you see matt jones you know and and this
this is a crazy thing i have to hold my
breath and i love mac jones but i have
to hold my breath because every game it
seems like he can throw three or four
interceptions guys are dropping it have
opportunities they're just not coming
down with it he has to do a better job
of protecting the football
yeah i think i think that's the big
thing is that you're seeing them start
to treat mac jones as a guy that can go
win them football games as opposed to
somebody who's protecting football games
it's funny right as all this stuff
happened with notre dame i couldn't help
myself i went back last night and i
watched the rose bowl from last year i
kind of wanted to see it from notre
dame's perspective going what was brian
kelly thinking and then i also wanted to
see it from mac jones perspective cause
i'm going how the hell is this guy able
to play in the nfl this immediately and
when i'm watching him throw the ball to
naji harris and throw the ball to
devonta smith he was already playing in
an nfl offense and he already had
essentially an nfl very similar to
belichick type coach in saban so he's
used to the pressure and the grind of it
all and to watch him go 25 of 30 300
yards four touchdowns in that game and
play perfectly efficient football it
made me realize the training he had for
this moment and now you're seeing him
pick it up within that moment
every belichick team that i watch just
gets better as the year goes on but when
you think about a rookie quarterback i
think that the curve just the curve of
how much better this team is going to
get heading towards february is going to
be scary for the rest of the nfl
and you look at josh mcdaniels and we
can't we can't overlook josh mcdaniels
in a terrific job that he's been because
he's in mac jones ear every second he's
talking to him during practice the
meetings all those different things i
thought he's done an impressive job of
getting him you know allowing him to
just play football spreading the ball
around getting it to different play
makers and the offensive line has gotten
better they continue to run the football
they pound people they use play action
pass and every now and then you see josh
mcdaniels rip out a couple trick plays
every single game it's terrific and as
much as i love coach belichick um josh
mcdaniel has been doing a great job with
this young quarterback
he sure has let's get to your second
take away we're going to keep it right
there in the afc really at the top of
the afc with the baltimore ravens team
that continues to win they've won in
some interesting ways to say the least
they've gotten behind they've come back
they've won sloppy they've won this
they've won that but the bottom line is
they continue to win what's the story
right now with baltimore
they're just a very resilient team
they're a very resilient team but
they're not going to go very far if
lamar continues to turn the ball over
too many injuries on offense too many
injuries on the defensive side of the
ball for him to continue to turn the
ball over and now i'm getting to the
point as much as i love lamar and i
think here in the next three to four
years he will win a super bowl but when
he drops back the pass he starts to get
me nervous a little bit and i like the
way that offense has evolved it's not
just mark andrews in the passing game
but he has to do a better job of not
turning the ball over you know his
defense stepped up played tremendous
with all these different injuries but
these are just easy passes i mean you
got to be able to complete these in the
playoffs you won't get these
opportunities you know you want you
would not be able to throw four
interceptions in the playoffs and then
come back and be able to win the game
because the teams in the playoffs are
they are a lot better and they're going
to take advantage of those opportunities
yeah i haven't i haven't been this
nervous like you're you're saying
watching lamar play since his rookie
year there was moments during his rookie
years going oh everyone talks about
but he had been a lot more efficient he
had been a lot more effective as a
passer recently so i hadn't really been
used to seeing this one thing that they
were doing and we knew going into the
game that this was a possibility is they
were using jeremiah iwusu coramoa who is
a safety linebacker combination played
that rover outside linebacker spot in
college at notre dame and now he's in
the nfl and he's really been the perfect
transitional piece for the nfl game as
the nfl continues to evolve
and he's not really a safety and he's
not really a linebacker and i don't
really think it matters what he was is
an incredible spy for lamar jackson and
you don't really see ever a defender
match up athletically with lamar and i
thought you saw two that were able to
match up athletically one was miles
garrett the other was jeremiah wusu
coromo and it started to get into the
head of lamar jackson i think he was
really lucky to find a way to win this
game
i tell you this and you're you're spot
on with that joe woods who i've
criticized on this show i've criticized
them a couple times i thought he had his
best game plan he came out he had
seven defensive backs and i i include
jeremiah as a defensive back because
this is a kid if they wanted him to play
strong safety he could play for strong
safety and be an all-pro but he can also
play linebacker but they had seven
defensive backs they had a ton of speed
on the field so anytime lamar took off
once he got past two of the most
athletic defensive ends you're gonna
ever see play in the national football
league you had all these guys swarming
you had nothing but speed i thought this
was the best game plan and joe woods
showed me a different side i don't know
if it was desperation or whatever but it
seemed like it gave his team a boost
they created four turnovers so i expect
him to continue
with the with these aggressive calls but
i thought he probably caught his best
game of the year
that's a great point that's a great
point if baker mayfield's healthy on the
other end of it
who knows they may capitalize on some of
the opportunities the defense was able
to create for this offense uh but
they've they've you know they've been
able to stop on some serious narratives
there in baltimore this year because
everybody would say that this style of
offense can't come from behind and lamar
he can't come from behind he needs the
lead they need to do power running to be
able to keep the lead run up the score
but has it been the case at all with
this team if you look at the kansas city
game that's them coming all the way from
behind with lamar jackson you look at
the minnesota game that's them coming
all the way from behind with lamar
jackson this most recent game was just
sloppy football to go beat the cleveland
browns but the thing that lamar
jackson's doing a little bit of is
they're they're hitting these quick
passes you know hollywood brown screen
hollywood brown five-yard turnaround
mark andrews five-yard turnaround
they're getting some of these young wide
outs on the outside going and then
that's opening up the power run game so
when they're coming from behind it's
weird it's almost like lamar likes to
run around and you know throw some
sidearm passes and get back to the
things he was doing so well louisville
it starts to open up make him feel
comfortable in the passing game and when
i watched that minnesota win from a few
weeks ago that was what stood out he
starts to get in his element behind
because he starts playing free running
around and having fun again
yeah and a big part of that is coach
harbaugh every time we talk to these
players and we ask them about you know
why do you guys play like this why are
you guys a close-knit team how are you
guys able to overcome they always go
back to coach harbaugh coach harbaugh
gives him freedom he gives them trust
and belief belief and he's one of those
guys that he always trusts remember we
were there this week here this year
the first time and he was like lamar
what do you want to do let's go for it
let's go for it like i've never seen
anything like that at a quarterback
being so young and had question marks
about behind them and things like that
i've never seen a coach ask a player
what do you want to do to me that really
showed me the nature of their
relationship like coach harbaugh is a
cool cool dude like he's always cool i
like him he's fiery i've known him for
years but at the end of the day when you
show trust in your quarterback a
quarterback like lamar a special
quarterback man look there's nothing
that lamar feels like he can't do on
that football field but it gives him the
courage to not
to be aggressive throwing a ball and
that's one of the reasons why he threw
four interceptions because he felt so
comfortable and confident being able to
throw the ball it didn't work out for
him they end up winning the game but i
think he will get better
it's an excellent point because for
somebody to throw three interceptions in
the second quarter alone and these were
like tip ball these were ugly looking
interceptions and then they come back
that first drive of the second half and
to be running right it's a third down to
be running right towards the sideline
and to have the courage to throw that
thing up in the air just like moon ball
going mark andrews he's over there
somewhere let's see what happens draw
that pass interference mark andrews
happens to catch the football and then
the other one when he's scrambling
around he's got garrett his face and he
throws another one to mark andrews that
was the touchdown down in the red zone
you don't make those throws unless you
have that confidence of your coach you
don't do it you can't do it unless you
have that kind of confidence and without
those two players
jack jack that's a third and four when
he made that play so it wasn't like oh
let's just be conservative and get the
first down no let's go for it i got my
best player against one of your best
defenders and i trust that he i'm gonna
throw it up he's gonna come down with it
and that's exactly what happened
that's a great point let's get over to
the other side of things with the
cleveland browns so here was coach
stefanski after the game
with that quarterback position and what
may be down the road here is what coach
had to say
yeah it's frustrating
it is very frustrating to uh not score
enough and it's always a combination of
things it's
you know staying on the field on third
down it's
trying to run the ball effectively get
into the red zone all those things but
we're just not doing a good enough job
and that starts with me is a quarter
night change at all a possibility in the
bye week no
won't
let me ask you a question why would we
do that
well the points you know just aren't
there yeah it's not that's we're not
doing that tonight
so this is this is a little weird to me
because
i don't think people are asking him
about a quarterback change because baker
may feel stinks i think people are
asking about a quarterback change
because baker is not a hundred percent
and that's the thing that i question
like if baker's 70 percent is case
keenum does he give us a better chance
of winning football games at 100
as opposed to baker at 70 because
there's a there's things that baker
can't do on a football field anymore and
it limits their offense you know so if
i'm kevin stefanski it's not about ego
and pride it's about doing what's right
for your team there's a reason why you
brought case keenan because he knows
your system you've coached him before
he's been around you a long time so you
should give baker a couple weeks at
least a couple weeks to rest jack you
said it you said look rodney i see him
he's not the same he's holding his
shoulder he's limping he's just
he doesn't look like a fluid athlete
when he's out there because he's in pain
if i'm kevin stefanski i'm giving him a
couple weeks it'll clear his mind it'll
help help his body physically and maybe
it'll rejuvenate them and then you can
see what you have in case keenum in the
future
that's next level and it's probably
something they should have done a few
weeks ago because then who knows now
baker might be healthy he might be
coming back you know what i mean and we
got to give credit to baker mayfield
because that dude is tough man he is
tough to have that kind of a shoulder
injury then another injury now you got
the heel injury now you got the knee
injury and for him to continue to want
to go play cleveland better know what
they have with baker mayfield going out
there and gutting it out and he's found
ways to win these games but this is
something at this point and i am in
complete agreement with you that's not
only better for baker mayfield it's
better for the cleveland browns because
they have won with keenum before
so put keenum out there see if you can
go steal a couple of games get baker
mayfield back to being and looking like
baker mayfield you're not gonna heal
that you know heal the groin injury with
three days off so what happened the
first time early on in the game it was a
second series of the game that baker
really tried to hit the gas pedal and
run
he pulled up again you know then he was
limping the rest of the game and if you
can't go do that bootleg stuff this
stefanski offense is not the staffance
offense and they're going to continue to
get beat
absolutely and that's why i say he needs
to make a move and a lot of times people
say
he doesn't want to probably cloud the
relationship between him and baker but
if i were him i would go to baker and
say look i watch you and i know how
tough you are you don't have to show me
your toughness anymore i'm gonna sit you
down for a couple weeks and i'm gonna do
what's right for this team and you know
because we think about it every time he
comes out and he's limping he's hurting
and he he has to do so much just to go
through a two-hour practice it's like if
you give him time to relax and just
really get treatment and take his time
he's baker's a very sharp guy he's going
to always still be in the meeting rooms
he's going to help case keenum he's
going to be on the sideline as a
different set of eyes but sometimes as a
football player you need rest especially
as a quarterback because nobody goes
through more than a quarterback mentally
physically and emotionally
you know during a football season
yeah and a whole nother element of this
is kareem hunt coming back was a big
story coming into this game but they
were going to get this two-back option
we know nick chubb's the star but for
them to get kareem hunt back and they
really didn't even give him the football
he wasn't even a part of the game plan
could you believe that watching this
game
i told you i'm like what the heck are
they doing i said you got two pro bowl
backs you have a bag that you can
legitimately line up as a wide receiver
as a playmaker and you're not even you
utilizing them you're not even putting
them on the field you're not even
putting them on the field with um with
nick chubb so i really didn't understand
the play calling i didn't understand
what um you know using the two two tight
end sets you're not really utilizing
these guys you can you can bring them in
and you can run the football or you can
spread them out and you can pass the
football with these guys but they're
really not utilizing these guys i don't
know what kevin stefanski maybe he's
starting to feel the heat and the
pressure of everything that's going on
oh i'm sure they're all starting to feel
a little bit let's get to the la teams
right the la teams let's start with the
chargers right because the chargers both
the teams are struggling in la right now
but the chargers and justin herbert i
think it's you know it's the team that
one week you go oh wow that's that's the
potential super bowl you know they can
host one right there in their home city
and then they're completely gone the
next week so what's going on with
herbert and the chargers
well he's feeling he's justin herbert is
feeling the pressure of all the
expectations you think about the rookie
year that he had last year he was
phenomenal last year he came in started
the first game he didn't think he was
going to start and was out and was
absolutely terrific this year defensive
coordinators have had a chance to study
him a lot more and so they're doing
different things they're showing them
different looks you look at wink
martindale with the baltimore ravens
bill belichick mike zimmer
they lost to all those great defensive
coordinators why because those guys
blitzed them showed them different looks
created turnovers doing did the same
thing that denver broncos did to them
and justin herbert is starting to feel
the pressure because they're saying oh
we have a new coach we got the young
stud and justin herbert second year in
the offense we can he could take us to
the next level and he's just not the
same quarterback right now he's learning
a new offense so checks and adjustments
and all these different things he's
learning on the fly and it's gonna take
time but the one thing that's been a
saving grace and we talked about for
justin herbert has been the fact that
he's been able to run and to use his
legs and use his athleticism that really
helped him out against the um you know
pittsburgh steelers when we were there
yeah you know when you hear tom brady
talk and he goes you know why would i
retire now when i got all the answers to
the test like i have the answers now uh
it's something you almost got to
remember with young quarterbacks like he
he may know how to beat one defense but
there's always going to be a second or a
third different look that teams are able
to give them and i think you're seeing
some of those secondary or third just
different you know adjusting the scheme
showing them one thing pre-snap changing
to this defense that are just fooling
them so some weeks it looks amazing
other weeks not so much like he looked
awesome in that game against the
pittsburgh steelers we were out there
for that sunday night football game
throws the game-winning touchdown down
the sideline and then you just didn't
see any of that this past weekend so i'm
not giving up i'm not panicking on
herbert i just think he is learning that
there's more than one test out there to
pass and he's gonna have to continue to
do so you wanna get to your fifth
takeaway right here on the defensive no
let me let's go
yeah let me make one more point now
during james he's been excellent for him
and they have both and they have a lot
of good young pieces but i never trust
the defense that can't stop the run if
you can't line up and you can't stop the
run when you gotta have it and this is
what happens in january that's what
happens in december and january
if you cannot stop the run you can't you
can't go very far in the playoffs you
can't because it's cold the weather is
crazy and you have to be able to either
get a first down or you have to be able
to stop somebody from getting the first
down that's the bottom line and i don't
think they can do it consistently enough
there you go that comes down to defense
so this defensive player of the year
race we've been talking about this one
all year long on this show where do you
lean right now as you look at that award
and who some of the stars on defense are
this year it's two it's two guys clear
cut two guys is matthew judon who's been
basically everything eleven half sacks
he's been tremendous he's come in and
really helped propel that team i mean
whether it's the pressures the sacks the
leadership you know just everything that
he does every single day he's come in
he's really made a difference and the
the most athletic guy i've seen i think
is in the nfl miles garrett he's just a
freak athlete when he jumped up and
knocked that ball down some of the
things that he's done
i've never seen on a football field and
he is a big dude six four six five 280
pounds super athletic and did you see
the way he chased lamar jackson down and
caught him he is an absolute freak these
are the two guys in my opinion now i'm
going to ask you who are your two guys
that you put up there are you with me
against me
you chose you chose some pretty good
ones right there you chose some pretty
good ones like miles garrett would have
been my number one honestly um and i
thought miles garrett did a lot he's
number one almost as much as he could
have done right right yep he almost did
as much as he could have done to go try
to win that game against baltimore he
only plays one position you know i mean
i at some point you probably should have
put him in there at running back seeing
if he could help the offense too
i mean you mentioned the play where he
where he looped back around and lamar is
going down the sideline i mean there's
there's defensive backs and cornerbacks
and safeties that lamar regularly
outruns in that scenario so to see miles
garrett who is a step behind be able to
catch up to lamar jackson and push him
out of bounds i just never seen anything
like that and if you watch the browns
play all year
miles garrett makes those kind of plays
on super athletic running backs or
receivers anybody that gets in the zone
of miles garrett he has a way of getting
on the ground and then the one where
he's flying five feet up in the air like
you mentioned too so he's doing things
that defensive end just should not be
able to do his pressures are there 59
pressures on the year that second in the
nfl 16 of those sacks he got all these
hits hurries like you look at his
numbers miles garrett has the resume
right now to win that award
no doubt no doubt those two guys are
playing fantastic really anxious to see
how they finish up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports